[Music]
many Europeans have gone to fight for
Isis close to 6,000 of them and those
are just the ones we know about
with the Caliphate crumbling many of
these foreign fighters are hitting home
but what should be done about them on
November the 13th 2015 eight suicide
bombings and a gunman attacked Paris
killing 130 people and injuring more
than 400 the attackers were French and
Belgian nationals six of whom had
returned from Syria where they had been
fighting with Isis also known as ISIL or
Islamic state these people that training
they've had connections with extremist
groups if we look back at the sort of
major jihadi battlefields in the past 15
years we can see pretty much every
single one of them has produced
individuals from the sort of cohort of
people who went out there as foreign
fighters who have emerged as a terrorist
problem back home what to do when
fighters return is a major concern for
Western governments one solution is to
make sure they never come back many
foreign fighters have been killed on the
battlefield
James mattis the American Defense
Secretary says his aim is to make sure
the rest won't survive the fight to come
home those who do survive will face
legal obstacles a number of governments
including Britons have passed new laws
to try to prevent fighters from
returning where they have dual
nationality I have the power to deprive
them of their British citizenship and
keep them out of our country but under
international law no country is allowed
to make its citizens stateless and most
of those British fighters are likely to
return to the UK in the end according to
one security think tank of the 850
British citizens known to have joined
Isis half are already home
around 1/3 of German and 1/4 of Belgian
fighters have also returned and in
France the Western European country with
the most foreign fighters 271 have come
back governments have to decide what to
do with them you know if there's a case
that can be built against the individual
that they participate in atrocities or
they committed atrocities while they
were fighting alongside Islamic state
due process will kick in and they will
usually go to jail even going to live in
Isis territory is a crime under EU law
locking up returning fighters
demonstrates a tough stance from
government and reassures the public but
prison poses its own risks many
jihadists have previously been in jail
before committing attacks the
government's own officially appointed
inspector into the problem of Prison
radicalization and said that the problem
with out of control that the prisons are
jihadist training run at the moment
convicted terrorists should be behind
bars but not all returning fighters fall
into this category whose sama hasan took
part in jihad in the 1990s when soviet
forces invaded afghanistan i'm a former
foreign fighter and a portent of terror
started when i was 19 and of course that
was all legal in those days and they
loaded order here around the arab world
i was willing to take up arms and fight
and die for a noble cause and that's
what i think we have to recognize and
understand is a lot of young men and
women to become the terrorists are
motivated by noble ideals but noble
causes many foreign fighters travel to
syria long before Isis emerged and the
brutality and the headings began they
went to defend fellow Muslims in the
uprising against President Bashar
al-assad
others went to live in the newly
declared Islamic state in search of a
more pious life
there are a lot of people who thought
that going to Isis is they're going to
building you a table in society very
Mironova spent seven months embedded
with the iraqi special operation forces
in mosul trying to understand what makes
Isis fighters tick I was able to visit
Isis houses where they need foreign
fighters their basis to see what books
they read how did they leave and there's
like very interesting things were
finding like love letters and cooking
recipes it's very important to show and
to understand that people in Isis or any
other group they're normal people many
who went to live under Isis have seen
and done terrible things those who felt
the Caliphate did not live up to the
utopian propaganda wanted out but faced
imprisonment if they went home
we hear people say you know lock them up
and throw away the key
the whole point of our society similar
society is to give people a second
chance and give them a chance of
rehabilitation
not many governments are willing to
offer returning as a second chance but
in Denmark they're giving it a try
instead of prison sentences some get
counseling and help finding jobs and
housing the aim is to combat the root
cause of terrorism
there are a group of people in every
country basically that if you eliminated
that they feel that everyone is against
them that they are basically very
unhappy with the whole situation and
then a group comes and this puts an arm
around them and says oh come on come to
us we're gonna help you with Isis almost
defeated on the ground it may seek to
step up terrorist attacks around the
world
[Music]
the Danish authorities hope that former
fighters reintegrated back into society
will feel less alienated and
disillusioned traits that Isis
recruiters prey upon
but critics cite and lack of hard
evidence that the Danish model is
working and rehabilitation is a hard
policy to sell I think politically it
will be very difficult for the
government in a Western European country
to take individual who's been fighting
alongside a proscribed terrorist
organization like Isis or al-qaeda that
has made an avowed intent to launch
attacks on our country and for the
government to spend a considerable
amount of money basically giving this
person a life it only takes one or two
determined individuals to carry out an
atrocity so close surveillance of
returning fighters is essential even
those in prison may eventually be
released but keeping a close watch on
just one person long-term takes a lot of
manpower so governments face the
difficult decision
of whom to watch and whom to ignore
you